hello everyone so it seems like we are
going to have another online semester in
a number of different institutes across
the country
now in the previous two youtube videos
that i have made in the comments section
i have received a number of requests
asking me to share some tips for this
kind of an online semester so i thought
it would be a good idea to make this
kind of a video
now before making this video i went
through youtube looking at such uh some
similar videos sharing some tips for
some online semester uh and i noticed
that many of them share excellent points
but they grossly miss out on a number of
important points so through this video i
wish to emphasize on some of those
important points
uh these points i have broadly
categorized into four parts the first is
the approach or the mindset that you
need to have regarding this online
semester
next how to actually go about attending
the classes the mechanics of it
third how do you follow up those classes
those online classes and fourth how do
you deal with the assignments and tests
very important so let's first go into
the approach of the mindset that you
need to have
so
this is a point which i have found which
is lacking in almost every other youtube
video
which they never make is that
they never mention
uh anything regarding the possibility of
bad online teaching so this is not from
your perspective rather from the
perspective of the professors
so you see
there's always the possibility that
there will be some professors who
absolutely do not care
they'll be extremely bad at teaching and
this is true whether the semester is
online or offline we are not talking
about that situation okay
what i'm actually talking about is the
problem that even if the teacher is
actually good in a physical real
classroom there is a possibility that he
or she may not be very good in online
teaching because of whatever reasons
maybe he or she is not very technically
savvy
or maybe he or she is having some other
problems in conducting the online
semester
it results in some kind of very bad
teaching
another possibility is that suppose the
teacher is maybe somewhat relatively
young he or she is very technically
savvy she's willing to put in the effort
despite all those best intentions he or
she may not be teaching very well
because
you have to understand that in this new
paradigm of online teaching none of us
are very experienced we have barely like
18 months of experience barely 18 months
okay so we are not very good at this
ourselves none of us are
okay so there is always the possibility
that we are going to screw up you have
to accept that possibility and when you
actually
go in for your online semester if you
see that you are facing difficulties
because of the teacher not realizing
some of your difficulties and problems
and constraints please please make sure
that you give some kind of constructive
feedback or constructive criticism in a
very polite way to your professor so
that
because he or she is having the best
intentions
they can actually improve
next
uh this is from your perspective now
from the students perspective that
there is always a temptation for
students to goof off during an online
semester okay because they are not being
constantly monitored directly in front
of the teacher there's always the
possibility that they will goof off
you must remember
that
you should treat an online semester your
online class is just like regular
classes never ever let yourself be left
behind it is extremely hard to catch up
next
uh again on this point of get of
catching up
you have the recordings of many of the
lectures okay many of the institutes
have made it mandatory for the
professors to record their lectures
whether it is synchronous or
asynchronous teaching
the
lectures will be recorded
now when these lectures are recorded
there is a great temptation for the
students
to kind of
slack off
and then
suffer from the delusion that later on
they will catch up by looking at those
recordings of the video lectures
this is not going to happen what is
actually going to happen is that things
are going to pile up in the different
courses and they'll never be able to
catch up
okay so please do not
fall under this delusion that you will
catch up by looking at the recordings
next regarding the actual classes how do
you uh
how do you go about
attending the classes now the first
thing is regarding the
the technical things that you will need
now my personal feeling is that a mobile
phone is
good
but
a
a desktop or a laptop is better
now
i understand that for many indian
households
there are certain financial constraints
and
just by saying that
that you go and buy a new laptop it is
not possible
so what i will suggest is that you just
give it a serious thought that you need
not buy a new laptop
okay so you buy a second hand laptop now
the problem is that if you buy a
secondhand laptop the new versions of
windows is not going to run okay
certainly windows 11 is not going to run
if your laptop is like five years old or
six years old
okay and even if windows 10 manages to
run on it it will not run properly okay
you will find uh actual problems so what
i suggest is that if you have little bit
of courage
buy a secondhand laptop which will come
which will come much less expensive and
try to install linux in it
there is a good benefit to this is that
it can actually help you add a bullet
point in your cv you see if you if you
know windows this is not not something
which you can mention your cv nobody
cares whether you know windows in your
cd if you write like that but if you can
write that you know actually linux then
that actually creates an additional
bullet point okay especially if you're
not from a computer science background
it kind of creates a good impression
that that you are kind of
having that extra technical sadness
so try to keep that in mind and if there
is at all some financial constraint go
for a mobile phone nothing too expensive
okay the next important point is that
if possible try to have a dedicated
workspace or a dedicated study space
where you can just sit down every day
for your online classes again in the
indian context i know in many many
households this is wishful thinking it
is not possible just because i say that
you have a dedicated study space it is
not possible especially if you have a
joint family kind of situation
sometimes you may have to sit here
sometimes you may have to sit there
sometimes you may haven't even have to
sit in the kitchen
now people who are suffering from these
kinds of apparent problems you don't
think that you necessarily are at a
disadvantage okay so the situation is
like this
so
it is common wisdom that people will ask
you to study at a particular place
and people who are
sitting in different different places
will feel at a disadvantage but you see
in an actual physical classroom nobody
actually sits for all their classes at
the same place
okay usually okay in most institutes
what happens is that one particular
course will be held in one particular
classroom maybe another course will be
held not in not just in another
classroom but it may be in another
building so they have to go from one
part of the campus to another part and
do their classes there now this change
of setting can actually help in memory
formation actually people have said that
the kind of environment that you have in
different different situations that can
actually reinforce your memory for
example the kind of friends that you are
sitting with in a particular course that
can actually help in creating certain
memory connections
so
if even in your own house you are
sitting at different different places
maybe that can actually indirectly help
you so don't just think that you are
always at a disadvantage
regarding the actual classes
regarding the actual classes
uh i strongly strongly advise you that
you set up a morning routine okay all of
your classes will inevitably start in
the morning you set up a morning routine
get up
clean yourself up
make your bed this is very very
important okay recently there was some
kind of a viral video
on some kind of a army or naval officer
giving advice on the advantages of just
taking 10 minutes time in the morning to
make your own bed how it sets you up
beautifully for the entire day there is
great wisdom in that try to follow that
okay so
and uh
have your breakfast and like as if you
are actually going for your classes with
that kind of seriousness and uh
and nice clean uh need attitude you sit
down for your classes wherever it may be
okay so that will really help you
please do not fall into the delusion
that you are just going to lie around in
your bed lazily under your blanket
winter is coming now uh
and uh you are going to watch your video
by holding your mobile phone in your
head uh in your hand under your blanket
that is not going to help you you can
watch entertaining videos on youtube
like that
classes you cannot attend like that
actually you can attend
but it will not point it is not going to
help you
next
uh when you are actually attending
classes
even if even if everything is being
recorded make it a point that you sit
down and take notes directly live in the
classes as if you are actually sitting
in a physical classroom this is very
very important
okay
please also make sure that when you are
making your notes keep separate exercise
books or notebooks for different courses
okay
i know some people can take it to the
extreme like they will have different
color codes and
different stickers and whatnot for these
things i am not asking you to do that
much okay just keep separate exercise
books for everything a certain
discipline is required for attending
online classes actually this advice of
making different notebooks is actually
ah true for offline classes also see i
was always a student of offline classes
and i tried both ways when i first went
to college
i tried to make a single copy for all
the subjects because that was the cool
stuff to do
i realized it doesn't work okay it
completely fails it's a massive disaster
okay so if you are doing like that
i let me tell you from first and
experience you are not cool you are just
stupid don't do it okay
telling from experience
again i will emphasize here that when
you are present in your classes be
actually physical i mean mentally be
present in your class okay when the
professor is maybe asking something try
to respond to it okay i know many of us
are very very introverted we are
we are unwilling to open our mouth in
front of others but try to push yourself
just a little bit try to get out of your
comfort zone a little bit try to respond
okay
the good thing is that in an online
class nobody's seeing your face so there
is one less extra shyness to overcome
just make your voice be heard try to ask
the professor at least one or two
questions a week
okay so that way you will also feel a
certain connection to the subject and
once you develop that connection i can
guarantee you that you will
automatically be able to focus and
devote yourself more towards that
subject and perform well next
i have mentioned about the importance of
taking handwritten notes but it is all
it is true that in an online semester
there will be innumerable
lecture notes video files ppts this and
that that will be shared by the various
professors of the different courses
these will all be in digital format
now usually what happens is that in
various institutes you will have some
kind of course management system like
microsoft teams or moodle or blackboard
or canvas or whatever
and
everything will be there in the cloud
okay now
it is an extremely bad habit to keep i
mean to keep yourself reliant on that
cloud
okay
my suggestion is that you download
everything you download everything to
your computer or whatever system you're
using
and keep your files locally
okay please please do not depend on the
internet connection to later device
furthermore if you have the things
locally
uh you understand that later on i mean
when you pass out
and you maybe need to come back to these
things to device
if you're in a core job
you will have the things ready at your
hand
okay you because once you pass out you
will no longer be part of that course
management system like moodle or ms
teams okay so
how can you access those if you are only
studying from those things it is always
best to download those things locally
now this brings me to a very important
point which i have seen many of the
current generation students lack and
which is that they
suffer from an inability to organize
their files uh properly
okay what they will do is they'll
arbitrarily download everything keep on
downloading everything and dump it
everything down all the files of
everything in the downloads folder okay
things will be there but if i ask them
to just pick out a certain file from a
certain week they will have to rummage
through it ransack through the through
the entire folder for two three minutes
even to find out one file this is i mean
quite a stupid way of approaching it
rather you in a separate drive or
whatever
file system you are using
make separate folders for the different
courses
uh make different fold the subfolders
within that
like lecture notes uh
maybe tutorial sheets uh maybe
assignments to be submitted uh whatever
okay so you know i mean set up your own
system okay and i i can assure you if
you look up on the internet on youtube
there will be innumerable such videos
asking you to go for this kind of
digital system and that kind of digital
system the only common thing that all of
those
i mean suggestion advice videos have is
that none of them will work for you
individually different parts of them are
very good like but the entirety of none
of them will be good for you so you set
up your own system be comfortable with
your own thing okay but keep them
locally another very important thing is
that once you have your system once you
have your files structure and everything
you must must make it a point to keep
backups this is something which i always
tell my students
certainly my phd students to always
always keep a backup
okay you cannot understand the or
realize the importance of it unless you
lose it okay so maybe one week before
the exam or whatever the
important
deadline is you realize that somehow
some kind of technical snag has happened
and you have lost all your files then
what do you do will you run around uh
asking and begging if all your
batchmates for help okay i mean it's
it's a disaster okay don't do this if
you have a backup you can quickly
restore it
next regarding the
assignments and tests
you see in this online semester for the
professors this is a big big challenge
the evaluation process assignments and
tests and they'll have to rely on some
kind of an of an online system uh maybe
through moodle uh or some other uh i
mean there are assignments in within
microsoft teams also so some some kind
of online system they'll be following or
maybe some kind of in-house
system
in the institute
whatever it is there'll always be some
kind of deadline maybe at 11 pm on
certain date you have to submit
something
now whenever you receive such a deadline
in your head you always understand
i mean you take the date and you take
the deadline as minus one hour of that
so if the actual deadline is 11 pm you
think that the deadline is 10 pm
and try to submit your assignment or
test or whatever the thing is
by that time
okay the reason is that these online
systems can somewhat be flaky flaky
means something or the other will go
wrong especially the last moment when
everybody is trying to sum it something
or the other goes wrong okay i am
telling this from first and experience
it has happened many many times only in
the past it has happened
okay so at that last moment if you say
that such and such technical problem has
happened no professor is going to
believe you okay they have other
problems i mean 100 other problems to
deal with they are not going to listen
to you
next for online tests what i have seen
is that
because we professors know that
by the very nature of the online test
it is going to be open book and
certainly open internet i mean you can
look up everything you can google
everything it is certainly not a test
for memory we cannot set up our system
like that
so the tests happen to be
more and more difficult so you have to
be really really proficient and good at
your subject to be able to perform well
this is very very important not many
people realize this okay like in an
actual physical test maybe the questions
are not that difficult now one way uh
which in which you can significantly
make your life easier is to have some
kind of a programmatic framework to
automate some of the repetitive tasks
for example in many of the technical
courses you will find
and this is irrespective of the
department you will find that you will
have to calculate eigenvalues or
eigenvectors or maybe you have to
calculate determinants and this is not
just for linear algebra mind you okay in
many of the mechanical engineering
courses we have this and i'm sure even
in electrical engineering and other
other departments you have this
so these kinds of things
you can easily program and keep it ready
at your hand maybe uh in python or
matlab or whatever
you are comfortable with so the moment
these things come you can quickly
calculate these things without the extra
overhead of doing these things manually
or in a much more difficult and
cumbersome way in your calculator okay
so
these are certain important things
which i wish to especially emphasize on
uh i have left out many of the other
things uh so please feel free to
put in some of the important points
which you think are also
extremely important in the
in the comments section and i would just
like to end this video with one extra
thing
is that
if it is indeed true that this is really
the last online semester we are going to
have
my suggestion is that for the last time
enjoy your khana enjoy your mom's
cooking for the last time properly okay
all the best